so I have six different expressions here
and what I want you to do is pause this
video and try to calculate the value of
each of these expressions I'm assuming
you've given a go at it now let's work
through them so when we see something
like this we have to remember our order
of operations we have two times three
squared and we have to remember that the
first thing we need to think about are
the parentheses parentheses I'll just
write paren for short then we worry
about exponents exponents exponents then
we will worry about multiplication and
division and actually let me write it
this way we worry about multiplication
and division and then we worry about
addition and subtraction so in this
expression right over here there are no
parentheses so we do the exponents first
so we calculate what 3 squared is 3
times 3 is 9 so this becomes 2 times 9
which is equal to 18 now let's look at
this one this one is interesting because
we they have its it looks like the same
expression but now there are parentheses
and because of these parentheses we were
going we're going to do the
multiplication before we take the
exponent so 2 times 3 is going to be 6
and we're going to take that to the
second power so that's 6 times 6 which
is equal to 36 now let's think about
this one right over here once again we
want to do our multiplication in our
division first so we have a division
right over here 81 over 9 is the same
thing as 81 divided by 9 that's going to
be 9 and then we have subt becomes 1
plus 5 times 9 now we want to do the
multiplication before we do the addition
so we're going to do our 5 times 9 which
is 45 so this becomes 1 plus 45 which of
course is equal to 46 now let's tackle
this one right over here so we would
want to do the exponents first so 1
squared well that's just going let me do
this in a different color 1 squared is
just going to be
equal to one so that's just going to be
equal to one and so you have two times
four plus one what should you do should
you add first or do the multiplication
first
well multiplication takes precedence
over addition so you're going to do the
two times four first two times four is
eight so you're going to have eight plus
one which of course is equal to nine now
you have a very similar expression but
you have parentheses so that's going to
force you to do what's in the
parentheses before you take the exponent
but within the parentheses we have
multiplication in addition now we have
to remember that we do the
multiplication first so we're going to
do the two times four first so that's
going to be eight plus one plus one to
the second power eight plus one is nine
so that's nine to the second power nine
squared not or is the same thing as nine
times nine which is equal to 81 now we
have one more right over here that
looked very similar to this one except
once again we have parentheses that's
making us do the addition first without
parentheses we would do the
multiplication in the division first but
here we see that 1 plus 5 is 6 and then
we have this 81 over 9 which is 9 so
this simplifies to 6 times 9 which of
course is equal to 54